mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
angoissés par la prolifération des
numéros à deux au cabaret des deux
pistes j'ai décidé ce soir non sans un
certain courage de vous présenter un
numéro seul en quelque sorte un numéro
de soliste
voilà courageux mais qui est-ce qui s ok
ce que je vois mais vous êtes ici je
vous crois d en tournée je débarque à
l'instinct alors je sais que vous
passiez courageusement ce soir 20 heures
au petit cabaret n'arrive pas ou alors
je me suis dit allez allez allez
alors je vais aller à un tour assez
jean-pierre offs et à doha à 37 ans
pense et j'en passe et j'en j'ai pensé
justement je suis extrêmement sensible à
cette attention
alors je vous invite alors à laisser
aller a dit allez-y la jv oui mesdames
mesdemoiselles messieurs oui quand même
pas dans les petites secondes des toits
michel vous jouiez à pontivy je crois
oui a entre autre vie oui j'ai joué à
pontivy
vous avez fait un immense mérite à
pontivy mme suire loire nesles la vallée
c'est ravissant et qu'est-ce que vous
jouiez en tournée et en tournée je lui
sont claires de rostand et quel rôle le
meilleur pour la pauvre bête est alors
après issoudun dammartin en goële je ne
sais pas si vous connaissez non
carpentras en les berlingots et puis
alors lourdes lourdes abri mais londres
n'est fait qu'une apparition je présente
et puis alors que j'ai terminé en
apothéose un certain yahya d'agde à les
hôtels de verne harris assez le coup de
fusil si j'ose dire oui j'ai triomphé
sans foi saverne un mois on joue
toujours à elle à la salle saint joseph
1 1 en jeu maintenant l'immaculée
conception
oui ça ne soit pas de la famille et il
est bien équipé c'était moi non je suis
assez luxueux mais remarqué qu'il ya un
petit restaurant là tout près et
d'étangs d'eau derrière la gare dans
leur coin droit main vous le connaissez
j'ai fréquenté cent fois non et puis et
bien encore jean pierre maintenant pour
15 france pour combien 15 30
je vous demande pardon mais les
restaurants un tournus pour les
comédiens si ces capitales s'étaient est
essentiel que je suis content d'avoir
envoie araud alors alors le menu vous
avez pour quinze fois vous avez du
saucisson à l'ail
vous avez dû poireaux vinaigrette il
avait une tranche de viande large comme
mes fesses vous avez dû cas les noms des
salades yaourt et flins et flore louis
marette à l'or fin et services compris
15 15 c'est pas vrai c'est pas vrai mais
c'est pas cher dit voix dont jean-pierre
à part vos petits monologues de gugusses
dans les petites boîtes de la rive
gauche
alors qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
faites je suis submergé c'est déjà
quelque chose pour un comédien oui parce
que je joue tous les matins attali dans
les écoles jeu et attali vie du doubs
racines oui oui je connais qu'est-ce que
vous jouez dans un livre l'arel la
marraine at-elle c'est pas possible
c'est pas possible entre investi ça
alors c'est palpitant charles
oui parce que j'ai constaté qu'il n'y
avait plus en france une tragédienne
pour jouer le rôle c'est possible c'est
beaucoup trop et soufflant beaucoup trop
dur c'est possible c'est possible alors
un comédien confère au personnage plus
d'autorité et de plus de noblesse
possible c'est pas si possible tous
avaient l'air ça vous intéresse de bosco
j'ai ça vous intéresse pas ce que je
ferais jamais ça me passionne ça me
fascine alors écoutez j'ai mes valises à
dallas l'a alors le temps d'enfiler leur
aide alors autant filer le péplum
il sait jouer et je les jours bien je
profite de l'absence hélas momentanée de
jean-pierre et oui va revenir ça
m'ennuie autant que vous je profite de
son absence pour vous aviser que je vais
jouer les classiques et alors pour la
tragédie classique je pense entre nous
que il a un physique un peu un peu
insuffisant sans méchanceté tout ça a
duré bien un petit peu insuffisant mais
enfin
ça fait un peu tranche napolitaine et
vous y tenez vos la aux fleurs en
couronne lalana les fleurs c'est
essentiel à amiens tally avec des fleurs
pour les enfants ça fait plus qu'un vrai
bon il écoute beaucoup mieux alan boss
avait il les compte alors par instant là
tous ces petits bambins sont tranquilles
et on peut faire n'importe quoi et
amiens puis alors tenez je ne vous en
dis pas plus que ceux ci ça c'est
important
voyez la qualité mais petit d'homme est
ed catmull dit c'est pas la peine de les
passer alors vous avez acheté sachets
chez cora non marché saint-pierre
complètement et que ça bouge ça ça vaut
ça ne bouge pas pire max au pot les
détroits à la fois là non pas de folies
répondu t'es plombs ça ça c'est du plan
annoncé laurence d'essai du peuple en un
aux relents est alors comment vous
l'avez ça a tout bêtement après le
spectacle je rentre à l'hôtel mais je le
mets dans mon petit lavabo avec le savez
tant paillot du ca y est en pavot de
savon en paillettes je tourne je tourne
alors la crasse dessin c'est rare
qu'elle monte et je rince à grande eau
chaude et nantes y est sinon sa faune gg
sort oui et alors vous alors vous
repassez les vélos comment je reste
comme ça 5,6 euros c'est sec mais alors
vous ne dormait plus non mais je suis
propre mais ça me fascine je le
déshabille ça me passionne alors écoutez
je vais vous dire à faire tout à fait au
hasard un ver d'apnée commun vous jouez
vous jouez aussi amené à vis à vis je
joue tous les personnages janvier pour
les enfants c'est plus clé alors il ya
une petite subvention je suppose savary
dès que 18 100 francs juste de quoi
jeter mais trash et de la vie sont
graves
les beaux-arts pas pour tout le monde
pas d'aigreur alors si besoin était vous
me donnez par-ci par-là une ou deux
indiqué mais je serais ravi c'est il
faut s'entraider dans métier choses ont
traîné vous serez mieux peut-être la
jemmerais longtemps vous m'expulser des
gens n'ont même pas passé par une deux
indications un fait vous y êtes
je suis tout ouïe tous tous au seco
j'avais un c'est beau comme un rugbyman
pardon mesdames et messieurs multiples
silence parce qu'il se passe c'est pas
facile
pas facile non c'est de la tragédie
c'est un drame pour ceux qui font rire
dans la tragédie
j'y vais oui non et non comment non non
non vous dites oui oui j'ai ouï vont des
fans en avant jeudi constitue alors
affirmé le jean pierre marc marquez de
davantage c'est important la tacc du
vert or les cours dispensés vous
distancez trop c'est trop précieuse vie
attention cette tragédie mark et moi
savoir qu'il voit ça un peu comme ça
vous comprenez d'abord oui non ah bon je
vais je vais essayer c'est vrai que oui
c'est une c'est une bonne affirme assez
compte des meilleurs affirmation jean
pierre
oui on fonce et j'en connais pas
d'autres lacs janssen oui voilà en soit
là à ce point là vous êtes doué vous et
j'ai passé quatre ans au conservatoire
mais mais en laissant jean pierre on
laisse en laissant tous les 4 mois je ne
me lasse pas eu non plus je suis sont
faits on puisse enfin on renouera n'est
pas comme ça que tf1 je viens au que
c'est bon oh que c'est bon je viens
oui ah non pour vous venez vous voulez
oui je viens je vaux le partage
il va évincer c'est c'est le même
problème à bord alors il est vrai les
deux termes du verre est un sinon le
verbe ouattra et vous n'irez pas loin
mais un peu comme ça oui je reviens oui
je m'essayais me tarabuste ce nonobstant
je viens oui ils le voient bien que je
viens puisque j'arrive là là je vous
écrivais votre clown
là je reste coi ben écoutez comment
alors comment effacer au moins alors je
j'enchaîne oui je viens
oui c'est bon ça dans son temps c'est
pas mauvais dix doigts vous et m'excuser
sa victime et ses pensées pas c'est pas
vous ne jouez pas le temps la longère
d'habitude on joue toujours le temple
dans tous les subventionner j'ai touché
toujours vu jouer le temps mais ça
dépend des subventions avec mes 18 cents
balles peuvent pas de temps chez musker
alors comment comment vous le jouez vous
jouez à dorénaz comment vous le faites à
doha alors adoré très simplement je
jouais les mains comme ceux ci est je
pense un peu la tête vers la gauche oui
avec live avec l'hiver douala vers la
droite programme de giscard alors
pourquoi on l'éternel alors pour
l'éternel poussez-vous un peu parce que
j'ai un mouvement péplum life au 23 mai
les
lévrier
me
c'est pour donner nous ce sont des
terres mythiques the trance et éternel
époque c'est gratuit c'est travailler
c'est buriné ces fouilles rc oui peut
que vous aimez au poids du tout écouter
ça je vais être très franc
j'aime beaucoup le oui il pleure tout le
reste alors je ne sais pas du tout mais
qu'est ce qui vous arrive
je chiale oui telle intention d'humilier
longtemps comme ça mais écoutez je ne
vous oublie pas j'en tiens vous êtes du
trot th re
moi j'étais tout content pour voir
j'arrive je met mon mieux je dis je dis
oui on dit non quand même vous
schématiser la bouche et match s'avérait
bien que c'est un métier qu'on peut pas
faire n'importe quelle autre on est tout
le temps soubie d'évron ce qu'a fait ok
écoutez vous regardent leurs héros ça me
gêne l'aï vos gardes là car attaque
comme un taratata littoral atteint les
gens me regardent mais oui et toi vous
ils vous regardent y en a au moins deux
ou trois caisses qui à en parler c'est
fini ce gros chagrin b d'ab déboiser
bessieux cbi table ça ne peut pas
travailler dans ces conditions je peux
le peut alors quoi vous quittez le
spectacle a plein d'idées
pas mal à écouter en partant faites
attention à l'avant dernière marche
pourquoi mais parce qu'elle gagne rien
nulle autre pareille